the idea that we're exploring yesterday
was local time because if you have a
think about the earth and our where our
so okay so if it currently you know
quarter to nine in the morning in
Australia then it doesn't make sense for
our time to be the same as everywhere
else in the world because Riza's you
know here we are you know facing the Sun
because we can see it so we're on that
side of the earth which means that this
side over here is in darkness so color
really makes this percent 8:45 in the
morning so we have this we introduced
this idea of local time out of necessity
because not everyone is experiencing the
same time of day and everyone else we
all experience different times of day
and we're all experiencing that at the
same time because while we are in light
someone else is in darkest so
simultaneously this is this is weird
right it's just physically true at
exactly the same time we experience
gives many different types of days
someone's in the morning someone's at
night someone's in the afternoon and so
so that's why local timing things and
local time is defined based on which
meridian on one beach you you are on
right so where do we go sorry surely
there we are so here we're in Sydney
that everyone on the same yridian as us
it's experiencing 8:45 in the morning
right so time depends on all I should
say local time depends on the breed in
your own okay we did know yes there
there was one important exception where
even if you're on the same britney's
your time can vary wildly what was that
exception the International Dateline
which you can see here where is it now
our good perfect
I'm just looking for the spot at the
corner yeah okay so this is an old timey
glyphs which is why you can see the
International Dateline starts up here at
the top
right I waved around the top dribble it
weird around forth it's waving around in
between Russia and Alaska over here on
the eastern side yeah
I waved back and forth is a few islands
there now if you have a look at this one
it pretty much goes straight down across
the Pacific and there's just a tiny
little wave here right as opposed to
what we saw yesterday right as it's
promised finally differently on a
variety different matters everyone gives
you a slightly to feel that what's this
about little remember what's going on
you yes I get myself Islands right so
the particular island adhere the line
Island which is that particularly go
right across the widest equator there so
you have a line is any international day
line waves around
[Music]
I don't know let's have a look let's see
I I think it's in the ocean
I think of the ocean so if you want this
blue line here this strip is the equator
and I'm pretty sure yeah that's this
dotted black line is the Prime Meridian
so you can see it lands kind of there
off the coast of Africa that says the
Gulf of Guinea I don't think there's any
land there they bite they might actually
be but here do okay so local time this
is the reason we have it and remember
local time depends on the breed so for
instance if we describe two places they
might have a completely different
latitudes so I might say hey let's say
40 degrees a spot like this and I've got
a spot a completely different latitudes
so something like 20 degrees because the
two locations share a magnitude giving
them went for the moment I think here in
camp these guys have the same local time
if they're 40 degrees love them like
this 20 degrees of the same with it
but like there's no hungry tiny little
difference okay so we're talking about
if this is the same yeah yeah question
so that 40 degrees north and the 20
degrees south ocean ocean plantings were
what they indicate is are you above or
below the equator where so this is above
the equator Harrison this is below the
equator seven hemisphere now if these
guys are the same for example suppose
over for you agree rule that would mean
they're both in the same latitude the
same particular so the same small circle
that goes around like this but that
means they could be anywhere on this
circle and therefore they would all be
on a potentially different radios so
they could all have different times so
therefore this is important because you
get provided these coordinates and
they'll give you both when you want me
to do that liquid at home I must learn
to ignore the lattice here the ladder
connector effect except for that
exception the International Date Line
which is a bit crazy new instrument that
is with or organs like this okay there
for me or from now so it is not first no
idea however if you think about it it's
going to be completely impractical for
you to say if I'm off by like one degree
do you remember by the way what we said
one degree was equal to in time what
degree is forbidden right so if we said
because fifty degrees is an hour and 350
series a day if we said every time you
go one degree across and change your
longitude you have to change back your
clocks four minutes or change ahead your
box four minutes that would be crazy
they'll be really impractical because
not that you don't have to drive that
box to go one degree or quieter so I'm
going to say however it's impractical to
precisely change i whatever local time
you're sitting on your phone on your
watch based on your exam
which precisely change time based on
your pants want me to you
so since we don't want to just you know
what drive a few kilometers and then say
what we're in a different time from
where we were before
instead of that we have standard sizes
and you can see a bunch of them here so
our 15 degree slices if you have a look
I'll do business so you can see you've
got these 15 degree slices so each one
represents a power and everyone within
that theoretically shares the same time
we don't go Plus for business - for bids
as we go within that slice we just say
okay everyone here is exactly the same
time